oh my god
kaylee cuoco is finally getting her due
this is a dream come true
the actress snapped her first ever emmy
nomination on tuesday an
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series category
for her role on the flight attendant
when i woke up in the morning
[Music]
he was so alive
i think they know you're lying
kaley is up against fellow nominees aidy
bryant for shrill
alison janney for mom tracee ellis ross
for blackish and gene smart for hacks
but it didn't stop there the hbo max
show earned a nod for outstanding comedy
series
the flight attendants
hung over in thailand the kaminsky
method well
oh my god the flight attendant which
kaley executive produces
also earned seven other nominations
including honors for directing
editing and casting i can't believe it
after starring in the big bang theory
from 2007
to 2019 kaley took a more dramatic role
with a flight attendant
i mean it's 12 years of my life we've
all had a lot of ups and downs in the
last 12 years we're very close
group and we you know we have a legacy
of this show it's a special
show and it's something that i'll never
experience again it's something i'll
have for the rest of my life it's
something i'll probably compare every
project to like nothing will be like big
bang
and it just is what it is and it's it's
um made me who i am it's given me
so many great things and blessings and
i'll be very indebted to
to the show and to chuck lurie forever
but in those 12 years kaylee was snubbed
for her work on the sitcom
while her co-stars earned award show
nominations and accolades
i have cried a lot of tears but now it's
happy tears
the 35 year old actress captioned the
major milestone video
first timer over here thank you ad
television academy for a moment
i will never forget nine nods for team
at flight attendant on max
thank you thank you to my entire flight
crew surreal
kaylee also released a statement saying
quote i can never have dreamt of a
moment like this
so surreal i am so proud of the entire
tfa cast
and crew for each and every one of these
emmy nods it is a massive team effort
bringing a show like this to life
and i'm so grateful to each person
involved thank you to the television
academy for this recognition
my heart is exploding kaylie spoke to
etie last year about why she chose the
role after the big bang theory
why was this though the right thing for
you to do post big bang
when you were choosing like what's going
to define me after what has defined me
for 12 years in the
you know i still don't know if it was
right or wrong it was
but i still i told you this for years i
have a very strong gut feeling and when
i saw this book
and i was thinking of what the next
project would be do i wanna do i wanna
option something what do i wanna do
when i saw this book and i read this
girl i thought oh my god this would make
a really fascinating tv character i just
thought that it would
and that's that's what i thought and i
thought hey anyone wanna make this with
me
then all of a sudden i was in new york
shooting it so
got a great team and three years later
it's amazing to see this come to life
because it really has been my baby i've
never been with anything from the
beginning